LINDSAY: Welcome, everyone, to tonight's on
the record Council on Foreign Relations meeting.
I am Jim Lindsay, the director of studies
here at the Council on Foreign Relations and
it is my great pleasure to introduce tonight's
guests of honor, Elizabeth Economy and Michael
Levi.
Liz Economy is C.V. Starr senior fellow and
director of Asia Studies here at the Council.
Liz has published widely on China and U.S.-China
relations during her time here at CFR.
She is the author of "The River Runs Black:
The Environmental Challenge to China's Future”,
which is a classic in the field and I highly
recommend it to those of you who have not
yet read it.
Besides writing books, Liz is a master of
the short form publication, contributing regularly
blog posts at the awarding-winning CFR blog
Asia Unbound, which I'm required by contract
to tell you this...
(LAUGHTER)
You can find at CFR.org.
Liz is also vice chair of the World Economic
Forum's Global Agenda Council on the Future
of China. And she serves on the board of the
China-U.S. Center for Sustainable Development.
To Liz's right is Michael Levi. Michael is
a David M. Rubenstein Senior Fellow for Energy
and the Environment and he's also director
of the program on Energy Security and Climate
Change here at CFR.
Michael's many publications have covered topics
such as arms control, energy security, nuclear
terrorism and climate change.
His book "The Power Surge: Energy, Opportunity,
and the Battle for America's Future," which
was published last year is a path-breaking
analysis of the energy revolution that's currently
undergoing -- we're undergoing here in the
United States.
Like Liz, Michael is also a master of the
short form publication format with his blog
at CFR Energy, Security and Climate, which
provides cutting-edge analysis, not surprisingly,
on energy, security and climate change matters;
and you can find it, too, on CFR.org.
But we're not here to talk about their success
in blogging...
(LAUGHTER)
Or about their previous books. We are here
to talk about their new book that they've
written jointly, which I could hold up here,
called "By All Means Necessary: How China's
Resource Quest is Changing the World."
So, please join me in welcoming Liz and Michael.
(APPLAUSE)
First off, congratulations on completing the
book. Since I got to see it at various stages
during manuscript form, I know how much time
and effort went into producing it.
And I note that they say you cannot judge
a book by its cover, but I think the cover
of the book is quite attractive. But presumably,
the title says something about the book's
contents.
So, at the risk of violating the moderator's
protocol, which is never to ask two questions
at once, I'm going to ask two questions at
once.
First, Liz, why by all means necessary? And
Michael, how exactly is China's resource quest
changing the world?
Liz, you go first.
ECONOMY: Thank you. And thanks very much,
Jim, for hosting this event. It's a real pleasure
for us to be here.
So, by all means necessary really refers to
all the tools that China brings to the table
when it goes out to secure resources from
abroad. These are tools that in many cases
other countries and multinationals either
can't or simply don't utilize.
Let me just talk about three. So, first, right,
when China goes out to get iron ore from Gabon,
from example, it may not simply have one state-owned
enterprise go out to -- to access that resource;
but rather, Xi Jinping, the president of the
country, will lead a delegation made up of
ministers and state-owned enterprises and
sort of lay out these vast trade, aid, and
investment deals.
A second way is that, in fact, you can see
that China is much more comfortable in striking
backroom deals, right? So, you can find Xi
Jinping or other members of his government
coordinating with other leaders of countries
to strike deals that will bring benefits to
either side.
So, I think that if you look at the way in
which China approaches its deal -- deal-making,
you see that it's a sort of different scenario
in many respects from the way that the United
States of our multinationals are able to go
out doing -- doing things.
The third one I'll just -- I'll just mention
briefly is sort of the ability of China to
bring low-cost financing to the table -- low-cost
labor. Here, too, this is something that makes
it very difficult, on occasion, for our multinationals
to compete.
LEVI: So, China's resource quest is changing
the world in a host of different ways. And
we talk about a lot those in the book. It's
changing the world through the impact on the
ground of its investments, in labor, in the
environment.
It's changing the world through the way it
-- its military increasingly thinks about
security for sea lanes and bringing the resources
home. And it's -- it's changing the world
through the impact that its resource relationships
have on how it behaves in the security council
and bilateral relationships.
But what surprised us as we worked on the
book and as we worked through this is that
for most of the time, all of those are overshadowed
by something much simpler -- the impact of
China's resource quest through trade.
China is an enormous country. And regardless
of what its strategy is, its sheer size, its
sheer demand for imports -- it's going to
have wide spread consequences for global markets
and for societies and for security as a result.
China's demand for resources ranging from
oil to iron ore has sent prices up. That has
consequences for the economies of countries
that consume these resources, that produce
them -- regardless of whether China actually
has any direct relationship with those; those
high prices have security spillovers, they
have governance spillovers.
So, when you come back to it, there are all
these things happening. We have to pay attention;
we have to deal with them.
But this one dominant piece may not be so
sexy -- may not have all the great stories
with it. But it really is at least one of
the central ways that China is changing the
world.
LINDSAY: Fair enough. Thank you for painting
the big picture. We can now -- sort of want
to drill down.
I suspect everybody in the room here has a
sense that China is emerging as a global powerhouse
-- that it's going abroad in search of commodities
and what have you.
But I'm not sure, Liz, that we have a really
good sense of where China is sort of focusing
its attentions and -- and sort of what commodities
it's going after.
So, perhaps you could just sort of paint for
us a picture of where China's -- Chinese firms
are operating, where they're particularly
concentrating in, what kind of commodities
they deal with; that would really help.
ECONOMY: Well, when you have the second largest
economy in the world that's been growing at
a rate of, you know, roughly, you know, 10
percent per year for almost 20 years until
recently, they're going after everything everywhere.
So, you know, we look in the book at minerals;
we look at oil and gas; we look at water and
we look at -- minerals, oil and gas, water
and...
LEVI: Land or food.
ECONOMY: Land, thank you -- and land or food.
And here, we see that China is everywhere.
It's in Africa, it's in Southeast Asia, it's
in Latin America and it's, you know, also
in advanced industrialized countries like
the United States, Canada and Australia; and
we look at those separately from sort of the
developing world.
So, it's not particularly focused, you know,
in one region. I mean, I think there's been
an enormous amount of attention paid to China's
engagement in Africa, for example. But we've
found that China's very deeply engaged, for
example, in Latin America, as well -- and
certainly in its own backyard in Southeast
Asia.
LINDSAY: Obviously Michael, you know, one
of the consequences of China going abroad
in search of commodities is that it's given
a boost to commodity prices.
And I think, you know, when -- when sort of
the Chinese economy really began to rev up,
you began to hear a lot of stories about how
in essence the Chinese are going to remake
these markets -- we're going to move away
from a market-based approach to the distribution
of commodities to its variously called state
capitalism where they would lock up commodities
under long-term contracts and it would really
fundamentally change the game. Is that what
you see happening?
LEVI: It's not what I see happening in most
cases. And more than that -- and I think this
struck us both as surprising when we're working
on the book -- there are occasions where China
not intentionally is actually leading the
world to a more market-based approach.
So, the piece you hear a lot is that China
is locking up oil and is going to move us
away from a global market that sort of separates
economics and politics to one where they're
much more intimately tied.
But what you find is even as China acquires
more resources -- gets more equity oil investment,
it's still trading most of the product on
the world market. It's still trying to get
a high price or as high a price as it can
for it.
And so, it turns out that the -- you know,
the world economy -- China may be big, but
the world economy is pretty big, too. It's
a powerful system. It's pretty resilient.
The -- the surprising case -- and I never
expected to find iron ore interesting -- but
this is the surprising case, is iron ore.
Iron ore markets are not like the markets
we think of where everyone goes and says and
sort of yells their buy and sell prices and
you come efficiently to a nice in-between.
It used to be one dominated by three big players,
by a handful of big sellers, a handful of
big consumers; they would get together and
do very structured negotiations every year,
come out with a price, everyone would pay
it. And then you'd come back the next year
and you'd do it again.
And when China entered this as a big buyer,
it didn't seek to upend it. But you had a
host of small Chinese steel mills, and they
all went out and they all wanted to get their
own deal; they didn't want to play that game.
And the Chinese government, for all its power,
wasn't able to get them to do what it wanted.
All those small players doing their own deals
created an opportunity for a real market to
emerge. And then a few other pieces catalyzed
action and over the course of a couple years,
the world iron ore market was transformed
from this structure -- a pretty political
one -- to a much more market-based one.
So, a surprising outcome; but again, I think
a sort of example where whatever impact China
has -- even if it's not the one you expect
-- because it's so big, it's going to have
consequences.
LINDSAY: OK. You know, the -- the notion of
Chinese companies going abroad probably shouldn't
have been surprising to people.
After all, U.S. companies, when the United
States became economically powerful, went
abroad as well. But typically, when U.S. companies
go abroad, they're not doing the bidding of
Washington D.C.
And one of the sort of flip concerns of the
whole China is going to recreate a mercantilist
economy is that Chinese firms being state-owned
enterprises -- SOEs is the in-house acronym
we use for them -- go abroad that they will
be doing the bidding of Beijing; that the
idea isn't necessarily to advance economic,
per se, but broader political interest.
Is this what you've found in the book, Liz?
ECONOMY: It's a -- it's a mix, really. And
here, too, as Mike said, it was a little bit
of a surprise, I think.
First off, yes, the Chinese government does
want to direct companies to certain resources
and the National Development and Reform Commission
sort of lays out what resources it needs and
it does put together these big plans for individual
countries.
But then it's up to the companies to decide
to participate in those plans. And in many
instances, we've found, you know, that investment
would be announced by the Chinese government
-- for example, in Brazil, there's been something
like $70 billion worth of investment announced
since 2007, but the realized investment is
about a third of that.
Now, part of that has to do with, you know,
challenges that any company would face doing
business in Brazil. But another part of it
has to do with the fact that, you know, Chinese
companies sometimes simply don't want to play
the way that the Chinese state is telling
them to.
The second thing that, you know, sort of is
a little bit different than what we had anticipated
in terms of the sort of overall control of
the Chinese government in the sort of resource
quest is that there are many more small actors.
So, it does vary by sector and -- you know,
oil and gas, they tend to be, you know, fewer
and -- and major players. But in the mining
sector, for example, you know, only a third
of the companies are state-owned enterprises
and, you know, the rest two-thirds are -- are
sort of smaller scale firms.
And you see them going out, right, without
any sort of permission or direction of Beijing.
And in many cases, they cause a lot of problems
for the Chinese government.
For example, in Ghana we saw last July that,
you know, the Ghanaian government kicked out,
you know, 4,500, 5,000 Chinese miners. They
were illegal miners; they were, you know,
their environmental practices were poor.
And yes, the Chinese government was upset
and there's a little bit of retaliation going
on. But in point of fact, it certainly wasn't
the Chinese government telling those miners
to go out and secure gold from Ghana. Thanks.
LINDSAY: Let's talk a little bit about impact,
OK? Because obviously, with Chinese companies
going out, they were a big factor behind boom
in commodities -- we saw over the last decade.
But now, when I open the pages of the Wall
Street Journal, what I keep reading about
is that commodity boom is coming to an end.
The great growth that Brazil received, for
example, because of a very sort of vibrant
Chinese market seems to have cooled down.
Is -- is something fundamentally changing
in -- in China's quest for commodities, Michael?
Is this a leveling out? Is it cyclical? (Inaudible)...
LEVI: I think the world is catching up.
LINDSAY: OK.
LEVI: And look, you have to look at individual
commodities one by one. But when we were writing
the book, we decided to start, instead of
with predicting the future, by looking at
the past -- and asked why is it that rapidly
growing Chinese demand for commodities drove
up prices so much in so many commodities over
the last decade?
Because the reality is, there are a lot of
things in the world where demand increases
rapidly and the price stays roughly the same.
My iPad doesn't cost more than it would have
a few years ago, but demand has gone up.
And -- and what you find in so many of these
sectors is that the lead time for development
is enormous. And to compound that, a lot of
them were expecting very limited growth and
so, they have to -- their sectors really had
to shift gears quickly in the places where
either the sector was more responsive or able
to be more responsive or they were already
expecting growth for a lot of other reasons
-- aluminum is an example; you didn't see
the same kinds of price run-ups.
But now we are seeing these areas catching
up. There has been a lot more exploration;
there is money put in, mines that take time
to develop and technological progress.
And we're seeing this in the United States
right now. We would not be having an American
oil and gas boom, ironically, if it were not
for China's global resource quest. The prices
would not have been there to prompt that response
that's happening here that's moderating prices
in turn, had we not had that initial spark.
LINDSAY: So, higher prices encourage producers
to invest to bring more production online,
which drives prices back down.
ECONOMY: Yes.
LEVI: Which stops them from rising too much
more...
LINDSAY: Much more...
LEVI: Further. Look, we're not going to -- to
sit here and predict exactly how the future
will turn out and you can out-surprise us.
But if I had to pick a surprise now, it would
be on the downside, because when -- you know,
the thing that can have the biggest impact
on prices is when the world turns out in a
way differently from what you expect.
We now expect continued massive growth in
commodities demand. So, if you want a surprise,
you should look for a surprise on the downside.
LINDSAY: OK. I -- let -- question on another
aspect of impact, Liz, which is the impact
of China's resource quest abroad on environmental
practices in other countries.
Obviously, you turn the TV on and you -- and
you have written quite extensively before
it was a lead story in the news about what
Chinese growth is doing to the Chinese economy.
Is China doing abroad the things we sort of
see happening in places like Shanghai and
Beijing?
ECONOMY: Yes. And so, even I think more broadly
than simply on the environment, when you look
at any issue of sort of governance, whether
it's the environment or whether it's sort
of corruption issues or whether it's labor
issues, we found that China at home is really
China abroad. So, if you want understand China's
impact abroad, you just look at whatever it
is that they're doing at home.
So, the fact that a lot of Chinese companies,
for example, don't undertake environmental
impact assessments at home means that when
they're in Zambia, they're pretty much also
not undertaking environmental impact assessments
-- if they can get away with it.
And different states have different capacities.
So, I think one of the other findings we had
was that the international systems can be
a constraining factor -- so that the way that,
you know, China can operate in, you know,
Zambia is quite different from the way it,
you know, can operate in Brazil -- even though
it may try to do the exact same thing.
But -- but certainly, there has been enormous
environmental impact from Chinese companies
going abroad. And it's a source of significant
tension in communities wherever you look -- whether
it's Latin America, Africa or Southeast Asia;
there's a lot of concern about what China
is doing -- what its enterprises are doing,
in terms of the environment.
LINDSAY: At this point, I'd like to bring
audience members into our conversation. I
have to ask people -- if you would like to
be called on, raise your hand -- I ask that
you wait a moment 'til we bring the microphone
over. Please speak directly into the microphone
and stand, state your name and affiliation.
I'm going to go all the way in the back -- we're
-- start in the back and bounce around.
Oh, OK -- I see.
(LAUGHTER)
ECONOMY: She was just waving at us up here.
Hi.
LINDSAY: Oh, OK. Well, do you want to wave
back and then move on? I'll start at the front
then, sir -- Dexter (ph), if you could.
QUESTION: Real alarm -- no. Liz, I wanted
to ask you on the financing side rather than
the resourcing side, how much of this would
or could happen without China's sovereign
wealth funds?
I mean, is all of this supported by CIC and
sovereign wealth funds or none of it? I don't
-- I have no idea.
ECONOMY: No, I think -- Jim Mann (ph), by
the way, since you didn't identify yourself.
(LAUGHTER)
But no, in fact, China's sovereign -- CIC
didn't really get into the natural resource
business until maybe five or six years ago;
and then it was directed by the Chinese -- by
Beijing to do so.
And so, a lot of what we've seen taking place
over the past 10 to 15 years is not related
to CIC investment. You know, the majority
of the finances come through X China, Exim
Bank or the China Development Bank -- those
are really the powerhouse players when it
comes to the Chinese investment in the resources.
LINDSAY: Fair enough. Right here.
QUESTION: Priscilla Clapp. I'm retired from
the State Department.
In the areas in which I'm concerned, China
is having to change its ways on environment
and social policies, importing labor, training
local labor. Do you see that happening across
the board, or is it just special for their
neighbors?
ECONOMY: So, Burma Myanmar, for example, I
think there is a process of learning going
on. And in terms of China's general corporate
social responsibility practices, there is
pressure coming from the bottom up, from the
outside in and from the top down.
And so, certainly there are NGOs, for example,
as you know, going into Burma Myanmar from
China and talking to local communities and
going back and saying to the Chinese companies
and to Beijing, you know, "We really messed
up here," right?
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE) Chinese NGOs?
ECONOMY: Chinese NGOs, like Green Watershed,
for example. You know, sort of undertaking
studies and saying, you know, "You need to
consult with local communities," right? You
can't simply deal with the officials, right?
You need to engage the local population.
So, there are -- there are people within China,
you know, at the grassroots level, who are
-- I think are bringing news back about what
needs to be done.
You know, we found that places like Peru,
for example, that in the first Chinese investment
back in the mid-1990s and the Shougang Mining
Company -- you know, terrible, terrible practices,
terrible reputation.
But over time, you know, as six, seven, you
know, eight more mining companies have come
from China, they're learning from Shougang's
negative experience. And they're taking advantage
of an infrastructure in Peru that's been developed
by western companies, right, and hiring western
consultants or even taking on a local, you
know, CEO to manage things -- to deal with
community relations and again, to try to do
things differently.
And finally, I would say -- and I mentioned
the top down. That really is Beijing recognizing,
I think, that its companies are causing a
lot of problems for their reputation -- and
the Foreign Ministry certainly feels under
enormous stress because of what the Chinese
companies have been doing, especially in places
like Africa.
And so, they're putting in place a lot of
regulations. I mean, the -- you know, the
Shenzhen Stock Exchange has a set of regulations
dealing with companies who want to go public.
You know, you can't have some sort of environmental
black mark against you, right? Exim Bank -- we're
not going to loan you money unless you've
done an environmental impact assessment.
But as, you know, we mentioned earlier, China
at home is China abroad. And to the extent
that any environmental regulation or -- or,
you know, stricture is somehow not being enforced
on the home front -- it's still not being
enforced necessarily abroad. I would say that
enforcement is spotty.
So, corporate social responsibility -- those
things are developing in China and they're
developing in terms of Chinese practices abroad.
But I would say we're still at a kind of nascent
stage.
LINDSAY: We're going to go over here. Sir?
QUESTION: I'm James Turner from the Daniel
Alexander Payne CDC.
You mentioned that water and food were two
of the other things that you were looking
at. Can you speak a little bit more about
those, particularly the impact on the countries
exporting to China and the human impact in
the potential for conflict?
ECONOMY: Sure. So, in terms of water, it was
a different kind of investigation that we
did, because we were looking at China's control
of water within its -- within its boundaries
and how it affects other countries.
So, you know, looking at the impact of what
China does with the Ili River, you know, within
China going up into Kazakhstan or, you know,
the Yarlung Tsangpo and how it flows into
the Bramahputra.
But just -- so, it's a little bit different
and we can talk about that. But the land issue
is one that sort of mirrors the other ones
a little more closely.
And here, too, one of the surprising things
we found was that China's actually not the
largest sort of overseas investor, right,
in land -- because what you read, of course,
is that, you know, China's some kind of, you
know, cookie monster, right? Just out there
gobbling up...
(LAUGHTER)
All the different land. But in point of fact,
the largest overseas investors are first Canada,
then the United States and then China. So,
I think that helps give it a little bit of
perspective.
But I think there is a different kind of concern
when the Chinese companies go out and invest
in land, and we saw it -- we've seen it in
Brazil and we've seen it in Kazakhstan. There
is this sense that these state-owned enterprises
are coming to steal the land somehow, right?
And there's just a -- a different nationalism
that arises that's a little bit stronger than
you see when it's a U.S. company or some other
kinds of companies going out.
And so, a number of countries like Brazil,
like Argentina put in place laws, right at
the time when the Chinese were really going
out, that they said were not in fact directed
against the Chinese, but pretty clearly had
a significant China component to them to limit
the amount of outside investment in their
land.
So, there's a lot of concern out there about
the nature of Chinese investment that perhaps
didn't exist quite as much for the earlier
entrants like the United States and Canada.
LINDSAY: Sir?
QUESTION: Thank you. My name is Roland Amore.
I'm with Oppenheimer.
I have an observation and a question. As you
know, the world commodities are transacted
in dollars -- U.S. dollars. And I think if
you look back over the last seven years or
eight years with the increased demand, it
wasn't as great, I think, as the prices suggest;
you had Europe faltering, you had the U.S.
And I think there's a good argument that could
be made that all the loose monetary policy
has actually exported a little inflation around
the world in the form of commodities. And
but that brings me to my question -- and that's
the one of currency.
As the official reserve currency of the world,
all the commodities are certainly traded in
-- in dollars. As China gets bigger -- and
they're making noises now about a change of
currency. They -- they can't be number one
unless they're the official world reserve
currency, or there's third party currency
-- a basket of commodities.
So, how does currency play into your observations
and your research?
LEVI: So, it's a...
LINDSAY: Want to take a crack at that, Mike?
LEVI: Yeah. So, it's a great question. Over
and over, throughout the research, whether
it's in this particular question or elsewhere,
what you find is the resource demand has a
very big impact. But for it to have these
wider consequences, a whole bunch of other
pieces have to come into place.
And because the resource part is sort of out
ahead, you don't see some of those following
consequences. And I think when you look at
the sort of -- the shift in the use of the
Chinese currency, this is one of those.
So, could China insist on its resource trade
being transacted and you want -- well, it's
tough. If it has nicely balanced bilateral
trade with a country and a lot of leverage
over it, then maybe it can and they'll be
confident that they can, you know, buy various
Chinese products and exchange.
But if it isn't, then you need things like
fundamentally different access to Chinese
markets, different regulation, different legal
approach so that people feel like they can
actually use Chinese currency as a store value,
not just as a technical way of going back
right away and buying the thing you were -- you
were planning to buy essentially as a -- sort
of a -- a very thin mask for a barter system.
So, while the resource piece I think drives
one part of it, you have to be looking for
the other pieces to come into place. And -- and
those are going to move much more slowly.
Those require decisions by China.
It's not just a matter of Chinese growth creating
demand -- it's a matter of very deliberate
transformation.
LINDSAY: Yes, ma'am?
QUESTION: Paula Stern (ph).
You talked about iron ore and I'd like to
talk about oil. And particular, in this world
where we've had OPEC as a cartel -- how China
plays in that world, both -- you know, more
importantly to me, going forward.
Demand is obviously there. But it seems to
me that unlike -- well, it's similar from
your iron ore situation in the sense that
you really do have a -- not a market operating
that China is trying to participate in. Can
you talk a little bit about that?
LEVI: So, I -- I've never been sure whether
OPEC is hugely influential or mostly paper
tiger.
But the -- but several individual members
of OPEC are clearly influential, whether collectively
or not, by restraining production and driving
up prices. And China's demand for oil has
been critical over the last decade in allowing
them to do that.
If you have several countries that want to
restrain their production in order to send
up prices, it is much easier to do that when
world demand for oil is rising rapidly. It
is much easier to divide a growing or even
stagnant pie than to divide a shrinking pie.
And what China provided over the last decade
or so was a growing pie. And that allowed
countries to restrain their production, make
more money producing less than they otherwise
would have.
Had Chinese demand not been growing, we would've
had a repeat, essentially, of the 1980s where
OPEC countries were not able to be restrained.
So -- so, China is really a critical catalyst
there.
I'll give you just one -- one quick historical
point. If you look back at the projections
made by various companies or by international
organizations circa 2000 for the world oil
market, the thing you expect based on the
sort of popular discussions is to see them
massively lowballing Chinese demand.
In truth, though, they don't. They greatly
overestimate how much the big old producers
will be providing. And because they overestimate
it, they get prices wrong. That I think is
at the core here -- is those two pieces working
together to drive up prices.
Now, you ask about the future. We now have
supply coming from all sorts of other places,
so it's not just countries that strategically
restrain it. And you have economic weakness
around the world and perhaps not as much oil
demand from China as people expected.
That starts to change the equation, and it's
why I'm skeptical that you'll see a repeat
of the last decade's run-up over the next
decade.
LINDSAY: OK. Sir?
QUESTION: Hi. I'm Sean Barnett from the Institute
for Defense Analyses.
And I had a question about what impact do
you see China having with all that they're
doing around the world on the ability of other
nations to obtain scarce resources -- scare
commodities?
ECONOMY: So, your question is basically is
China in some way limiting the ability of
others to -- to access resources?
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE) Right, right. Or perhaps
to drive price up to the point where it's
-- it's (inaudible).
ECONOMY: Well, I think, you know, it -- within
our book, what we've seen is really that,
you know, Chinese are enormously competitive.
And to the extent that, you know, their practices
as I mentioned as sort of backroom practices
can kind of shut out companies. I think that's
problematic, right?
They don't really have the same kind of Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act that we do. They have
something that's along those lines, but there's
actually no monitoring or enforcement capacity
associated with it.
So, I think they do provide a number of challenges.
You know, again, those sort of -- those tools
that I mentioned at the beginning -- the low-cost
financing, the low-cost labor -- you know,
being able to, you know, export, you know,
a hundred thousand or more, really -- a hundred
thousand to a million Chinese workers, you
know, to undertake these infrastructure projects
that go along with the mining projects.
I mean, I think that makes it challenging
for companies to compete. But I think as Mike
was describing, and in terms of the price
rises -- you know, the rise in commodity prices,
you know, it really depends on the market;
really depends on which commodity you're looking
at.
And in some, such as, you know, food stuffs
-- grain, other developing countries are contributing
to price rises. And so, there tends -- there
tends to be this, you know, desire somehow
or because China occupies so much space in
the media, you know, not to recognize that
there are other actors out there.
You know, India, for example, where we look
and see China in Africa and -- and other places
sometimes maybe not doing exactly what I think
-- India's often right side-by-side. So, I
think our book does focus on China, but it's
important to understand there are other actors
out there, as well.
LINDSAY: Julia? Yep.
QUESTION: Congratulations.
LINDSAY: Introduce yourself.
QUESTION: Oh, Julia Sweig with the Council
on Foreign Relations.
And I think about Brazil a lot. Both of you
have been there as part of researching this
book, but I'm not going to ask a Brazil question.
I want to ask a broader question, which is
you mentioned the downside for Chinese foreign
policy of having companies playing a little
bit too ugly in fields of afar in Africa and
that having consequences that are now being
felt back in Beijing.
So, a downside on the environmental practices
-- but what about the upside? Could you give
a couple of examples where China as a state
and Chinese foreign policy experiences the
upside of having such market power in different
regions of the world? And you can include
Latin America or Brazil, if you'd like. Thank
you.
(LAUGHTER)
LINDSAY: Any upside, Michael?
QUESTION (?): OK.
(LAUGHTER)
LEVI: Upside for China?
QUESTION: Yeah.
LEVI: Sure. Look, plenty of American companies
would love the support -- at least in some
ways -- that Chinese companies get from their
government when they're trying to secure investments.
And when you have a company that has the capacity
to develop a resource, getting access to the
actual resource is an opportunity for you
to profit.
So, when it goes well, you can make money.
It contributes to the -- it contributes to
the state. That's -- that's the kind of way
that China benefits.
I think there's a more diffuse way that China
benefits, as well. China, as a big consumer
of resources, benefits when resource supplies
are more abundant.
And to the extent that Chinese companies can
play a little bit differently -- can take
a little bit more patience out there; can
take the support of banks that give them low-priced
capital -- they can actually increase the
world's resource supply.
Now, that doesn't give China and advantage
over others because that leads to low prices
or lower prices for everyone. But it does
benefit China as a major consumer.
And in some cases, the benefit is outsized
in -- if -- in -- in areas where China is
the dominant consumer of a particular resource,
adding to the supply is primarily a benefit
for -- for China.
So, there isn't necessarily a pipeline where
it goes piece by piece right back into China
and, you know, everything is nicely sewed
up. But China can create conditions where
-- Chinese producers can create conditions
where Chinese consumers thrive.
LINDSAY: Sir?
QUESTION: Eric Stein from Eaton Vance.
My question is you hear all these horror stories
about when China goes into different countries,
particularly Africa, that the countries feel
used and abused at the end.
Are there any countries in your research that
you thought kind of had the best experience
with China and where other countries could
learn lessons from how best to -- if you're
a country coming in to deal with China?
LINDSAY (?): Any -- any upside for the recipients.
ECONOMY: Sure. I think you can -- you can
find at various points in time, especially
when the Chinese companies first go in and
when the Chinese are -- are coming in with
their largesse, right, those trade, aid, investment
deals. There's a lot of excitement about what
China is going to -- to bring to the table.
And in -- in some cases, you know, the Chinese
are going in and, you know, going in to invest
in mines that others have left behind, right?
And so, they're simply not profitable, you
know, from the perspective of a -- of an American
or an Australian company.
And -- and so, the Chinese are willing to
go in there -- again, and sometimes, you know,
with great patience and -- and losing money;
I mean, another thing that we discovered in
our research is that, you know, something
like 67 percent of -- of Chinese overseas
investment, not just in natural resources
but across the board, are -- are money losing
enterprises, which I think is pretty striking;
beats the world average by, you know, 17 percent.
(LAUGHTER)
So, that's -- that's pretty significant. So,
I -- I think in terms of one country that's
benefited -- I mean, look, Mongolia, you know,
certainly has benefited, you know, 90 percent
of Mongolia's exports -- most of which are
natural resources -- go to China. Fifty percent
of Chinese -- of foreign direct investment
in Mongolia is from China.
But does Mongolia feel thankful and grateful
to China? Not so much.
(LAUGHTER)
So, I think, you know, there's -- there's
a mix, right? And then some parts of one country
may feel benefit while other parts certainly
don't.
LINDSAY: Fair enough. Sir?
QUESTION: Thank you. Mark Finley with BP.
You know, the premise of your -- of your book
is kind of go abroad. And you mentioned the
example of U.S. and other western companies
going abroad early in their histories.
But the recent history is actually to come
home. And so, you know, the U.S. last year
had one of the biggest increases in oil production
in the history of the world.
And my question for both the panelists is
what lessons are Chinese government officials
and companies taking from the U.S. experience
in that regard, and are they the right lessons?
LEVI: I don't know that Chinese officials
have taken a macro lesson from the U.S. -- because
you're talking in particular about what's
happening in -- happening in American oil
and gas.
I doubt that there are a lot of Chinese officials
saying, "OK, we need private land rights,
open financial markets, so on and so forth
and then we'll have our own boom."
But at a tactical level, there is plenty of
learning going on. And you see this as a pattern
around the world. Chinese companies go abroad
-- not only to get access to the resource,
but to partner with others so they can learn
how to develop it -- to get access to technology.
But in particular, and -- and the U.S. seem
to get access to management expertise to learn
how you actually plan and develop these sorts
of projects.
And these aren't the kinds of things where
you can go license a piece of intellectual
property. You actually have to work alongside.
And so, you see Chinese companies, you know,
putting up the money for a particular piece
of acreage along this or that U.S. company
-- so, Sinochem taking a piece of Pioneer's
Resources in Texas, for example.
They're not doing that because they've got
an export terminal lined up and it's all going
to be shipped back to China. It's the expertise
and the understanding of technology that they
hope to ship back to China so that they can
develop their own resources. I think that's
the most consequential way that learning is
going on.
LINDSAY: You want to jump in here, Liz?
ECONOMY: No, that's fine.
LINDSAY: I'm going to go -- finally got somebody
in the back. I'm going to go in the back now.
QUESTION: Thank you. My name Genie Nguyen
from Voice of Vietnamese Americans.
I have one observation and a question. First,
I congratulate the book. I think the cover
is very nice. And I particularly like this
picture -- I think it does mean something,
doesn't it?
What (ph) make (ph) from the Southeast Asia
and from where all the conflict's happening
-- this little rock with the flag on it does...
(LAUGHTER)
Mean a lot.
And then the other observation is thank you,
Dr. Levi and Dr. Economy and I -- happens
to make me think of leverage and economy.
And my question is how do -- how does all
this -- what is the implications to our U.S.
economy? How do we leverage it?
And if I'm not mistaken, the U.S. has a lot
to do with China's rise recently, thanks to
Dr. Kissinger and President Nixon and all
the changes. And I believe that is a -- Dr.
Kissinger has in a way given out a guiding
hand to help China to move to this stage.
Now we have all the challenges and we're talking
more about how to embrace China and to better,
neutral, profitable for everyone globally,
especially from my country, Vietnam.
So, I'm asking you from your point of view,
what recommendations do you have for the U.S.,
for ASEAN and for Japan, South Korea...
(LAUGHTER)
LEVI: OK, why don't -- why don't we do one...
QUESTION: And me...
LINDSAY: Why don't we do one at a time before
we...
(CROSSTALK)
QUESTION: Let me just make one -- one -- one
quick (inaudible)...
(CROSSTALK)
LEVI: We've got a lot of -- we've got a lot
of recommendations...
QUESTION: No, no -- the Asia-Pacific rebalancing...
LINDSAY: OK, OK.
QUESTION: That's my...
LINDSAY: You've put an awful lot on the table.
Thank you. But...
LEVI: We have a lot of recommendations. I
suspect we can each offer up one.
LINDSAY: OK.
LEVI: And -- and let me offer up one that
comes from an observation that -- that you
-- made you ask what you ask, "What impact
does this have for the U.S. economy?"
The U.S. economy has been hurt by higher resource
prices that have followed it -- not for all
resources. There are places where the United
States is also a resource exporter.
But let's say for oil. What can the United
States do? The first thing the United States
can do is become more efficient in its own
use of resources.
The most straightforward way, both to remove
pressure on prices but also to protect the
US. economy, is to be more efficient in our
own use of resources through policy and through
technology development, which can then be
applied by others.
LINDSAY: Liz?
ECONOMY: I guess staying on the economic front,
you know, we are trying to push forward on
a bilateral investment treaty with China.
And I think we already have Chinese coming
to look at our land now -- you know, interest
in from Chinese agricultural firms coming
to buy up or invest in U.S. land. As Mike
mentioned, we have them, you know, taking
stakes in sort of oil and gas exploration.
So, I think -- you know, one thing that we
can do is to push forward on this bilateral
investment treaty while at the same time sort
of ensuring that strategic assets that we
have, for example, such as rare earths, maintained
within our own purview.
So I think, you know, we need to learn from
the experience of others. We need to look
at how China has behaved in terms of its resource
quest -- sort of protect our assets. But at
the same time, as you say, take advantage
of China's economic rise, its growth and its
very strong interest in investing in our assets
here.
LINDSAY: But you have plenty more recommendations
but you have to read the book.
(LAUGHTER)
ECONOMY: Yeah.
LINDSAY: OK, we -- we have time for one last
question. I have to remind everybody before
I ask -- recognize a questioner that this
meeting has been on the record, OK?
I'm going to go to the gentleman in the back
-- you get the final question.
QUESTION: Thank you. My name's Jamey Foger
(ph). I'm in the Navy.
And I talked to the Chinese navy for our chief
of naval operations. I saw in your book you
make many references to the South China Sea
-- that's of interest to us.
And the Chinese navy that we deal with in
the Gulf of Aden is a completely different
Chinese navy than we deal with in the South
China Sea.
We try to correct bad behavior in the South
China Sea by being there and being present.
They don't like it. But we also look for other
ways and we look at other institutions.
The Chinese have kind of pushed the Philippines
out of the Scarborough Shoal and the Philippines
has very courageously decided to take that
to the International Tribunal of the Law of
the Sea. I think they have a pretty good case.
In fact, they've got some very good American
lawyers working on this.
If that case goes in favor of the Philippines,
what's your assessment on the -- the change
or the potential moderation or modulation
of the Chinese and their behavior? Will it
have any impact or no?
ECONOMY: I -- I think it'll be interesting
to see what happens. I mean, the Chinese have
not recognized the Philippines, really -- their
right to go to the Tribunal. So, as near as
I can tell, they're simply not dealing with
this particular effort on the part of the
Philippines.
My guess is it won't have very much effect,
in terms of, you know, moderating Chinese
behavior. I think the Chinese are continuing
to push -- push out the nine, you know, dash
line, right? Their claims on the South China
Sea -- they're talking about setting up, you
know, an air defense identification...
LINDSAY (?): Identification zone.
ECONOMY: Thank you. An ADIZ similar to the
one that they just, you know, established
in the East China Sea.
I think the Chinese view this as an issue
of sovereignty even more than they do of resources.
So, I don't anticipate much modulation or
moderation when it comes to the sort of sea
claims on the -- regional sea claims on the
part of the Chinese.
LINDSAY: So, you see the Chinese dismissing
them?
ECONOMY: I see them dismissing them.
LINDSAY: You want to jump in here, Michael?
LEVI: I think that builds pretty clearly on
the analysis that we did in the book. I think
you identify a nice dichotomy.
And we look at the Gulf of Aden deployment
and that's where China's learning. But we
also look at the South and East China Seas.
And Liz emphasized this core point -- this
is not just about resources. And it's not
even just about freedom of navigation in the
sea lanes, which has a strong connection to
resources. It's about nationalism and sovereignty
and that's an extraordinarily powerful driver.
LINDSAY: I think you can see from the very
sophisticated and nuanced explanations that
Liz and Michael have offered up tonight why
"By All Means Necessary" is a terrific book
and why we are very, very proud to have them
as members of the studies program.
So, please join me in thanking Liz and Michael.
(APPLAUSE)
END